Australia's Fitzroy River is home to a
host of deadly predators and we've drawn
the attention of one of the most feared
we want to get away from the river
because their salt weaksauce all over
across there just a few minutes ago but
there's a small pool here so we're just
going to get the rest of our
measurements
this pup may only be a month or so old
based on the smallest rostrums that we
have this is a newborn this very
recently probably I approval so this
section of the river is a nursery ground
exactly travis has caught a tiny pup
incredibly its roster is already well
developed and that's crazy Wow look at
how small it is it's amazing to think
that something this small could get 7
meters long it's a newborn pup but I
still need to be careful I don't want to
get jabbed by the saw so it still has
its Sam biblical scar when the Fisher
borer in this rostrum the saw has a
protective protective membrane on it so
the mother is not injured even on a baby
fish the teeth are very sharp and just
by instinct it starts shaking his head
is trying to get away total length total
length of 70 6.3
194 rostrum link this is one of the
smallest sawfish Dave and his team have
ever caught this is just another
indication that this area right here
it's probably the pupping ground for the
freshwater sawfish there he goes we
didn't realize the tides were coming in
so fast at this speed it could drag
Donets upstream leaving the fish trapped
and vulnerable to cross
everything was so called here and told
out an hour ago and then the tide
started coming up man its current
something else we need to weigh measure
and tag these fish as fast as possible
the tides coming in so fast now that
we're just trying to process these fish
as fast as we can and get our net out of
the water because sticks and everything
is coming in
we're stuck here looks like Jeff
over there this water just really came
in so quickly
just like the flash flattery might be a
flashlight back in Arizona
feels like wrong hey we get off
total waste
eighty 3.7 rostral length twenty point
five you can see through the saw here
skins so fin still good see why these
young fish are vulnerable what else do
we need this fish has already been on
the water about a minute you need to get
it back in as fast as we can
there we go
still okay I think tides ripping so much
so I'm just gonna have to let her go
newborn baby girl look at her go
it's been an amazing day we hit the
puppy ground just at the right time and
found an important area for these
sawfish maybe that's why the Crocs are
here easy food
the presence of pups indicates this is a
healthy ecological system so now we're
going to fish all night to see if any
bigger juveniles are adult sawfish are
out there